[MUSIC PLAYING]
LORIN PRICE: Today, we
are here with Harshit
who is a senior ML
engineer with Quantiphi,
and we are super excited
to learn about some
of the machine learning
solutions built by Quantiphi.
Before we get
started, can you tell
us a bit more about Quantiphi?
HARSHIT MALIK: Sure.
So we are an AI ML
company at our core,
and we provide end-to-end
data as well as ML solutions
for our customers.
We've been around
for over six years,
and we have offices in
the United States, Canada,
and India.
We are also a Google
Cloud Certified Partner
and we have been awarded
the Google ML Partner
of the Year for 2017 and 2018.
LORIN PRICE: Awesome.
Can you talk more
about what it means
to be a Google Cloud Partner?
HARSHIT MALIK: Sure.
So we've been a
Google Cloud Partner
for about four years now.
And we have over 325 employees
who are Google Cloud Certified
Professionals.
So what this
partnership means to us
is that we are often at the
forefront of newest GCP tools
and technologies available.
We get to be in contact with
the product development team
in order to provide
solutions to our customers.
And also, we're able
to provide feedback
back to the product
development team
so that they can
better design newer.
Features.
LORIN PRICE: Great.
Tell us about QDox.
HARSHIT MALIK: Sure.
So QDox is an enterprise grade
productized document processing
solution.
So it's designed to handle
oppressive workloads
of converting documents
into usable data.
So it uses a combination of
traditional OCR and custom
deep learning models for
handling virtually any template
of documents and to convert
into a knowledge base which
can be leveraged for any
further business uses.
We have a ton of features
available in QDox,
so for example, entity
recognition, key value bearing,
digitizing unstructured
and structured tables,
digitizing charts,
graphs, maps, and so on.
And also under the hood, we
have an active learning pipeline
which ensures continuous
improvement of our ML models.
So any feedback
the user provides,
helps us in improving our
own ML models, as well.
LORIN PRICE: Can
you talk about some
of the specific
technologies that were used
when you were building QDox?
HARSHIT MALIK: Absolutely.
In order to keep our
design as scalable
and customizable as possible,
we used a lot of GCP tools
for building a solution.
From the start to the
end, basically, the user
has the option of
uploading their documents
to Google Cloud via multiple
sources, like you UI
or emails or simple
drag and drop.
All of these documents are
stored in Google Cloud Storage
as a staging area, which
triggers a Cloud Task which
sends out asynchronous triggers
to App Engine for processing
these documents.
So we use Vision API for
converting this image
and document into text.
And we also have
custom ML models,
which are containerized
and stored
in App Engine for handling
all of the ML tasks.
Now, the results can be stored
in various data storages.
So if you want
relational database,
you can use, for example,
a BigQuery or Cloud SQL,
or if you want a
no SQL database,
you can use Bigtable
or Firestore.
And if you also want any
visualization or business
analytics, you can
port these results
to any analytics
tool of your choice,
say Looker or Tableau
or Data Studio.
LORIN PRICE: What are
some of the challenges
that you encountered
when building QDox?
HARSHIT MALIK: We designed
QDox with an evolutionary
architecture so that it's
capable of recognizing
any challenges and adapting
to it in the future.
So some of the challenges
we faced were firstly,
we had data shortage issue.
So we realized that
if we need to provide
high standards of
accuracy, we might not
be able to cover all templates.
So user feedback is very
important in that scenario.
So we included the
active learning pipeline.
So anytime a user
provides feedback
for a particular document,
that document becomes a data
point which helps in
retraining our models
and ensuring that the accuracy
level keeps on increasing.
Secondly, another
challenge which we faced
was that earlier, we
had used Cloud Functions
for deploying our ML models.
What we found out that our ML
models were too computationally
heavy, and we would often
face a timeout issue
in Cloud Functions.
So instead, we used App
Engine, which integrates well
with Cloud Tasks, and it's
also able to scale up endlessly
for our ML models, as well.
LORIN PRICE: Great.
Well, Harshit, thank you so much
for being here with us today
and for sharing more about QDox.
HARSHIT MALIK: Thank
you for having us.
LORIN PRICE: If you'd like to
learn more about Quantiphi,
you can visit Quantiphi.com.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks for watching, and
stay tuned for more episodes
of Stack Chat.